- Please, if you love college football,
if you love cutting hair,
if you love fashion,
figure out what you love and
try to start a side hustle,
a podcast, a YouTube show,
and Instagram account
around that thing, that
thing that's your hobby.
The thing that you want to do laying
in your bed from eight pm to 12 at night.
This is the greatest era of opportunity.
YouTube, what's up, so, so
grateful that you clicked
and you're about to watch
a new YouTube video.
But before you do, 212-931-5731.
That is my texting community platform.
I'm doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there,
and also access, opportunity,
first looks in that
environment, 212-931-5731.
Join it now, and now to the video
you've been wanting to watch.
Yeah!
You got your perspective.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
- Ladies and gentlemen, you've
heard him on the podcast.
You've seen him on the video,
please welcome a success resources,
roaring round of applause for Gary V!
♪ Being broke made me rich ♪
♪ Never fell in love with the coco ♪
♪ Never had to hold up
the store with a 44 ♪
♪ Never had the door
kicked in by the feds ♪
- What up?
What up, what's up what's up?
(audience cheers)
Thank you, thank you, what's good Orlando?
Thank you, thank you.
Let's go, let's sit down, let's do this.
- [Woman] I love you.
- I love you back.
(audience cheering)
I love you back, thank you.
Thank you, sit, sit, sit.
Good afternoon, thank you.
So look, I think there's so many
different things to talk about today.
But what I really wanna focus
on is really the two extremes.
The more I spend time in
the business world, in life
in general, the more I
realize that the middle sucks.
That there's so many people
that got caught up in the middle.
And what I mean by that is
I really genuinely believe
that what makes a successful business,
and then more importantly,
much more importantly,
I think what really helps someone be happy
is really winning on the edges.
And what I mean by winning on
the edges is the following.
I've come to realize that
since at a very young age
I've been playing in the two extremes of
having a north star, a
perspective, a mindset
that has allowed me to be happy,
and then all the way on the other extreme,
be wildly and deeply in practitionership
and actually making and doing.
And even seeing this gentleman
wearing the clouds and dirt sneaker,
I'm not sure I'm ever
gonna position anything
or any product in a more
honest place from where I play.
Because really, I'm a complete byproduct
of somebody who lives in the
clouds and plays in the dirt.
And in the analogy I started this with,
which is the middle sucks,
I genuinely watched
people play in the middle.
They don't fully have a
strategy, when I say strategy,
they lack self awareness
of who they actually are.
They're deeply dependent
on other people's judgment.
There's a whole lot of hopes
and wants versus realities.
And they're just genuinely
not structured to be happy
because of the circumstances
of DNA, parenting,
environment, and that's the clouds.
It's just so fun to live a life
where you're not worried
about other people's opinions,
when you're not dwelling on the past,
when you lack the ability to
expect things from others.
Because what it leads to is
just a whole lot of happiness.
It also leads to all
the stuff I talk about.
When you genuinely are
happy about your process,
you're really enjoying what you do,
you've really tuned out both
the cheering and the booing,
all of a sudden so much good
behavior comes from that.
You don't buy dumb shit to impress people
because you're not worried
if they're impressed or they're not.
You do make content or start
things because if it fails,
you're not worried about them booing you.
You're not worried about the judgment.
It's just such an interesting place
and I will probably spend the
majority of my next 60 years
trying to get to a
place where I figure out
different ways how to
communicate this clouds thing.
Because it's extremely obvious to me
that my mentality, the way I
was raised, the serendipity...
And this is completely
driven by gratitude.
I get to stand up here because of the luck
of the moment that my
parents decided to have sex.
Right, 'cause this is a DNA thing.
I mean that, I genuinely mean it.
Like my perspective on life,
my complete and utter obsession
with not having any expectations
from any other human being,
having no expectations,
having zero entitlement,
genuinely not thinking I deserve anything,
still being in a place where...
And I was at the airport just now.
I took like seven selfies
before I boarded it,
some guy slides in, I saw
him watching the whole time,
slides in he's like,
"You ever tired of them?"
Like never, never.
(audience cheers)
How in the world can a human
being be tired of admiration?
It's too humbling.
I live a life where people think it's cool
to take a picture with
me, that's ludicrous.
That's incredible, I will never figure out
how not to lean into my humility,
but that humility comes from a mindset
that starts with deep self esteem,
and deep understanding that
other people's judgements
actually have zero, zero
impact on your life.
And I get to be the byproduct
of tremendous parenting,
to have that mindset.
Not everybody had that, my father didn't.
I know how my grandmother raised him
and I watch how his
actions go based on that.
So I stand here, Orlando, today
with deep gratitude for
the way I was built.
When I hear the accolades,
when those cheers come
it's so easy for me to default
into your cheering me as a byproduct
of a whole lot of great circumstances,
a whole lot of good parenting.
Which doesn't allow me to get high
or ever have an ego of not the humility.
I'm the byproduct.
I am desperate to figure out
how to put sentences together
to get you to understand
how much that's the game.
The reason I'm not
interested in talking about
becoming a millionaire is because I know
thousands of millionaires
who are miserable as fuck.
(audience cheers)
What I'm interested in is trying
to figure out how to get you to understand
why it's so fun for me
to play in the dirt.
What I'm interested in is
why does this work for me.
Why did it work for me?
Why does it work for
other people that I see?
Right, because most
people have no interest
in putting in the deeply, deeply,
deep, hours of work required
to actually be successful.
Let me save you a whole lot of time.
There's not shortcut or system
or program or magic formula.
If you wanna build
something that's meaningful,
and sustain it, it takes an
obnoxious amount of hard work.
In perpetuity, forever, bleeding
out of your fucking mouth.
(audience cheers)
That's just the truth.
You know, are there maneuvers
that borderline are illegal,
or, at best, wildly unethical,
that lead to short-term cash?
Yes.
Do 98% of those people
end up losing that money
or going into a very dark mental place?
Yes.
And if you're interested
in that, that's awesome.
Do you, I don't give a fuck.
(audience laughs)
You're not my sister, you know.
You're not my kids, I don't care.
What I care about is being
historically correct, selfishly,
and what I know is the
following, we live in a time
that is so opportunistic
it's wildly uncomfortable.
How many people here
are over the age of 40?
Raise your hand.
So for the people that
have their hands up,
we are fortunate to have
the context of understanding
a world pre-internet at scale that...
How many people under the age of 30?
Raise your hands.
You characters.
(audience laughs)
First of all, in my opinion,
deeply the most interesting
and best generation.
I hate watching old people
fucking shit on you.
(audience cheers)
I mean that.
On the flip side, you have
the unfortunate nature
of what you don't control,
which is you've never really
been punched in the mouth,
because the economy's been
too good since you've been a grownup.
So you're fucking delusional.
(audience laughs)
Let me say this, this
is is some real talk.
How many people have been running
their business for five years?
Raise your hand.
If you've raised your hand
and you're not crushing
it, you've got a problem.
And let me tell you what that problem is.
The last five years have
been the single easiest years
to build a successful business
in the history of fucking time.
So if you just raised your hand
and you're not winning
and you're not happy,
you're in a fucking shit spot.
I don't think that's a bad thing.
I think that's a take a step back
and think maybe this
isn't the right business,
maybe I'm chasing quick cash.
The reason there's so many fucking crypto
and cannabis and social media experts
is people chase trends, not
what they're good at or like.
(audience cheers)
Not super complicated.
People are chasing the next fast thing.
If one more fucker rolls up on me
in public and says they have a CBD brand,
I'm gonna punch them in the fucking nuts.
(audience laughs)
I know you do!
Fuck!
(laughs)Bro, I have a
CBD-infused beef jerky.
Great, dick, now what?
(audience laughs)
People think CBD is like
the fucking magic formula.
You're commoditized, everybody's got one.
It's now bad to be in the business.
Same old shit, supply and
demand, supply and demand.
My friends, I come here this
afternoon with one agenda.
To put pressure on the thing that has
always been tried and true,
self awareness and work
ethic lead to happiness.
(audience cheers)
We're living in a very dangerous time,
even though it's great,
because right now we are
in the white-hot moment
of entrepreneurship being cool.
I live the benefit of that everyday,
hence I feel a triple responsibility
to remind people that it
is an extremely lonely
and difficult venture to be
a successful entrepreneur.
Most people fail, and many will.
And god forbid the economy softens.
So many people are so over-leveraged
with raising capital or delusion
that they're gonna get caught.
And so it's just an
important time right now,
while it's still good,
for everybody to truly, truly realize,
it's so simple, the path to happiness
is actually wanting to
work 15 hours a day.
Whether you work nine or 11 or two or 30,
the key is you have to like it.
You're talking to somebody
who failed all his classes
starting in fourth grade,
'cause I didn't like it.
I was capable, I didn't like it.
I have so much empathy for
people trying to start businesses
who don't like their business,
or are not meant to be entrepreneurs
because I lived it for
the majority of my life.
The entire first chapter of my life
was being forced to do something
that wasn't naturally in me.
I mean, everyday of my life
now, 15 hours goes like a blink.
First period of eighth grade
felt like a fucking eternity.
(audience laughs)
How many people here hated school?
Just raise your hands.
So for everybody who remembers,
remember looking at the clock?
That shit didn't move.
I was like haven't we been
in science for an hour?
No, four minutes, fuck me.
(audience laughs)
What's crazy is I know a lot of you
are living that professionally, right now.
And half of you are doing
it because you think
there's the money in that thing.
Whether it's real estate
or crypto or cannabis
or T-shirts, or whatever it might be,
you're literally doing what you're doing
'cause somebody told you
or somebody you know made money in it.
And we have to break that.
You will never, ever win playing a game
that somebody else loves more than you.
(audience claps)
We also need a huge
conversation around patience.
You guys know I push this
shit if you follow me,
but it's 'cause I lived it.
You know what it's like
to go into a business
at 22 and know you're
signing up for 15 years
to build a business for your parents
and you're gonna leave with nothing?
That's what I did.
You know when kids are
like, Gary you don't get it.
I'm like, I fucking get it.
I fucking worked 15 hours
a day, seven days a week,
had no social life for 15 years of my life
to build a business for my
parents and bounced with nothing,
and had to start VaynerMedia
outta somebody else's
conference room 'cause
I had no fucking money.
I get it very simply, I
get it a whole fucking lot.
I get it the most.
I love when people are like,
oh fuck this guy, his parents gave...
My favorite one, his
dad gave him $3 million.
No, dick face, my dad had a
business doing $3 million,
I worked 15 years to build
the business to 65 million
and I left with owning none of it.
Now what?
Now what's your fucking excuse
Johnny pants motherfucker?
(audience laughs)
So you're talking to somebody who did it,
who left at 34 and started at zero,
and built what I've
built in the last decade
'cause of my experience,
my talent, I get that.
We all have different paths,
but people are impatient.
This goes back to judgment.
The reason so many of
you wanna win right now,
so fast, is you wanna
show other people you won.
This is why credit cards fucked everyone.
People wanna buy shit they
can't afford to show people
they're actually winning,
versus actually winning.
My friends.
(audience cheers)
My friends, listen to me,
we're in a deeply,
deeply complicated place
where we always worried about fronting
and impressing others, and
that used to be 13 people,
and now we live complete public
lives and it's everybody.
So it's compounded.
Everybody's taking a hike on the weekend
for the Instagram photo,
not for the fucking hike.
People are right now, subconsciously,
you don't even realize
that you're doing it,
right now if you took a step back,
you can't imagine how much you're thinking
about your holiday vacation predicated
on the photos you post,
versus the vacation itself.
We live in a world where
people yearn for affirmation
or compliments, which makes
them vulnerable to booing.
The reason so many of you struggle
and you don't post, with a negative hater,
or this, is because you
overvalue compliments,
which make you vulnerable to negativity.
This is something we really
need to start talking about.
Like why are you here?
Like why are we here today?
(audience member yells)
I love you too.
(audience cheers)
On some real shit, like
what are we doing here?
I assume, if you decided
to spend money on a,
what's today Monday,
on a Monday afternoon,
and listen to this shit that
you're looking for something.
Which is cool.
My curiosity is, what?
Because for me, if you're looking
for tactics, they're so easy.
I've been telling you, how
many people here follow me?
(audience cheers)
What, you think you're gonna get
something crazy up here today?
You know exactly what
I'm gonna fucking say.
(audience laughs)
I feel like Aerosmith up here.
I'm not playing new music.
I'm gonna play the fucking classics.
(audience cheers)
But the reason I keep doing this,
and why it's interesting to me is
I've learned in the
last decade especially,
but kind of always knew,
right place, right time,
right analogy, right moment, right?
To me, it's been fascinating
to watch people consume my content...
You know what's great about how I do it,
and how I recommend you do it is
read your comments, read your DMs.
I know a lot of you are mad
I haven't texted you back,
I get fucking 4,000 of them a day.
I'm texting 300 back, I
just can't fucking catch up.
But I'm telling you, I read that shit.
And the reason I read it is it allows me
to know what I need to talk about here.
You think I knew that people
were fucking super sad
because their parents
were paying for shit?
I didn't know that.
My parents didn't pay for my shit.
So I could've never known that.
It was the thousands of
emails in the last five years
that I've read from kids in their 20s
who finally reconcile the fact of like,
oh fuck my unhappiness comes from the fact
that my parents are
secretly paying for my life,
which consciously and subconsciously
makes me feel like a fucking loser.
Let me tell you something right now.
You wanna get happy real, real, real fast?
I don't know how many people
this is going to work for in this room.
But if you're in this camp,
if you are over the age of 22
and your parents pay for
anything, on some real shit,
you need to leave this
conference, call your parents
and say I'm never taking
another fucking dollar from you.
(audience cheers)
There is nothing more obvious to me,
out of all the listening I've
done in the last half decade,
that the thing I just said
is leading to a stunning amount of bad.
A bad between the kid and the parents.
A bad about that kid.
All their doing is
taking that money to look
like their doing something
which starts corroding you
subconsciously in a way
that you cannot imagine.
I'm telling you, living
on your own two feet
is foundational to happiness.
The resentment that you're creating
towards your parents, and the resentment
that your parents are going
towards you is remarkable.
It's really funny, 40 year
old crowd and higher, go up.
You guys remember when we were growing up
if your parents were gonna
help you, you borrowed money.
You paid it back.
We're not living there anymore.
And that's amazing.
Listen, as somebody who
grew up with not a little,
and has a lot now, I look
at my kids, I want to,
but I want them to be happy,
not look like their successful.
My friends, we are living in
an unbelievably special time,
one that the robots in 4,000 years
are gonna talk about as an important era.
(audience laughs)
And what's important about this era
is the clouds and the dirt.
This is the greatest era of opportunity,
it's also one of the
most vulnerable eras ever
because of that opportunity.
This is a game of going inside.
You need to map, here's a tactic.
You wanna write some shit down?
Here's one, write down in order
whose opinion matters to you.
- [Female Audience Member] No one!
- There we go.
But on some real shit,
the people's opinions that
matter the most to you
are the things that
you're most vulnerable to.
And you need to hack that.
That is a real important hack
because I am watching people
completely live their lives
based on other people's opinions.
From things that kinda make
sense, like your parents,
to things that make no fucking sense,
like a random comment
on your fucking post.
And so, for me, I come
here today with the hope
that three, six, 11
people hear me this time.
Because the reality is, is when?
Like I've given you the tactics.
I'll give them to you one
more time since we're here.
The only thing that matters, in the end,
is the ability to communicate
what you're trying to achieve.
No matter what your service is, B2B this,
commercial that, T-shirt, Tee that,
sneaker, ice cream, house,
bird, going for mayor,
whatever the fuck you're trying to sell,
yourself, the only thing
that ultimately matters
in the internet world is the ability
to communicate to others that thing.
That becomes the variable of
how many people you close.
If you are a tremendous communicator,
then more people will buy your thing.
It's not complicated.
The way to be a great communicator in 2020
is to win on the 10 platforms
that dominate the phone.
That is life.
Nobody here is going to fucking Hollywood
and starting their own TV show
on primetime or on fucking Netflix.
Let's stop fucking bullshitting.
Everybody here can put
out 23 posts tomorrow
on these platforms, but you're not.
How many people here consume my content?
(audience cheers)
No shot, anybody that
just raised their hand
is putting out 64 pieces of content a day.
You hear it, you see it, you
get hyped for 48 seconds.
You're gonna be super fired
up in another 40 minutes.
I'm gonna jazz you the fuck
up for the next 40 minutes.
(audience cheers)
But I'll be very honest with you.
That hit means nothing,
because next Thursday comes in,
and then you try to do
your first LinkedIn post,
but you don't know what to say, right?
My friends, the reason I'm trying...
Listen, three, four years ago
I tried to stay very far away
from mindset and motivation,
I hate that shit.
It's just that I can't understand
when I'm telling you exactly--
I've now put out three decks
in full fucking detail
of what you should do.
Everybody in this fucking
room should put out
50 to 100 pieces of content a day.
Do it.
Why one isn't?
Immediately, Gary I don't
have a DRock or a team.
Motherfucker.
(audience laughs)
I've been doing this
shit since fucking 2006,
I didn't have a team either
for the first eight years.
How do you think I got to having a team?
Patience and doing it.
So please, listen to me.
Everything you wish, everything you dream,
everything you hope to
accomplish out of today,
tactically, is completely
predicated on your ability
to make pictures, video and
written words across Facebook,
LinkedIn, TikTok, YouTube, Pod--
That's it, that's the answer.
(audience claps)
But the reason there's
a smattering of claps
is 'cause you know you
haven't been doing it,
even though I've been pounding it
down your fucking throat
for the last three years.
Which leads me to why?
And that is how I found
myself into territories
I never thought that I would
be making content about.
Your spouse, your
father, your best friend,
that bad thing that happened
to you when you were eight.
All the shit that is inside of all of us
that is created insecurity
to actually put out content.
That's it, that's it.
And so that's what's happening.
And layered on top of that is
the imagery of what success looks like.
That's something I'm
super passionate about.
I'm passionate in the utter confusion
that things lead to happiness.
That a car.
Like do you know how many
people DM me literally
shit like, Gary V, if I could just have
a fucking Mercedes, my
life would be awesome.
Do you know how many people right now
are plotting and saving to
buy a piece of clothing?
Why?
I'll tell you why.
They wanna wear that piece of clothing,
rock that handbag, have those sneakers,
to show everybody else
that they're successful.
We are in a great era of makeup.
Everybody's fronting,
trying to 'press everybody.
Why, 'cause you're insecure.
You actually care about
other people's opinion.
'Cause you were told
you weren't good enough,
because you got a chip on your shoulder.
I know about a chip.
Every single teacher,
except for Senora Kennedy,
big shout out to my Spanish
teacher in high school
that if she didn't pass me on charisma,
I'd still be in fucking
North Hunterdon High School.
(audience laughs)
And 98% of my friend's parents thought
that I would be a straight loser in life,
because the only ROI from
1990 to 1994 was your grades
and what college you were going to.
Now, it's flipped, that still exists,
but we also have an entire era of
did you put entrepreneur
in you Instagram profile?
There's a lot more to
being an entrepreneur
than putting it in your profile.
Like literally 99% of
people that put entrepreneur
in their Instagram profile
would be no different
than if I put rapper and
athlete in my profile.
(audience claps)
We need a reset, Orlando.
We need a big, big fucking reset.
The reason I feel different
than a lot of people
that kinda look like me is 'cause the shit
coming out of my mouth is different
than what's coming out of theirs.
It's not super complicated.
My shit is universal,
it's always been this way.
Building a true foundation
is how you build success.
It scares me, it scares me
how many people think there's a hack.
Let me just save everybody a lot of time.
If you think there's a hack, a secret,
a system or a quick
path, humans are smart,
everybody would then do it.
Let me say it one time for
the fuckers in the back.
(audience cheers)
I see you!
There's no fucking short cut, dick!
(audience laughs)
None, zero.
Okay, if you're willing to play with me
and you can sit back for a day or a week
and figure out why, or
who's got your control,
who you're insecure to, who
you're trying to prove to,
if you can get over that
hump, which is by the way,
when I look at this crowd,
six people, six people
are gonna take this talk
and finally say, fuck it.
The quickest way if you're
one of those six people
is to call that person and tell
them to go fuck themselves.
(audience cheers)
So that's the quickest way.
Obviously, if that's your mom you don't
wanna just call and be like, mom, yeah?
Listen, go fuck yourself.
(audience laughs)
You may wanna go with a
different path of like,
mom, I'm tired and I just
can't live this way anymore
and whether it's your fault or mine,
I'm just done living
based on your opinions,
and I'm gonna do me, and
that's what's gonna happen,
and I'll see you on the flip side,
and if you were right, cool,
and if I'm right, cool.
That's what's happening.
(audience cheers)
I appreciate that, and a lot
of people aren't making it.
Because here's where it gets confusing.
A lot of people aren't making the call
because they don't actually
believe in themselves
that they're actually
gonna win the debate.
You know it's really fun to go call
your parent or your sibling or your spouse
and be like, you know what, fuck you,
I'm gonna start that baking
company, and I'm gonna kill it.
But if you actually think
you're gonna fail, you really lost.
That's why you're not making the call.
And a lot of people do that.
A lot of people love to front.
They're like I'm this, I'm
that, but that's just talk,
and you use the other person
as an excuse no to do.
It's not them suppressing you,
it's you're scared to jump
and you're blaming them,
and acting as if they're suppressing you.
My friends, life is very simple.
It comes down to the actions.
The enormous ability for people
to talk about what they're gonna do
versus them actually
doing it is staggering.
I watch people all the time
tell me what they're gonna do,
and they're putting in
four hours a week on it.
They're like literally
watching entire seasons
of shit on Netflix more than
executing on their thing.
It's because they're escaping.
Netflix, and 2K, and the new
DaBaby album, that's escape.
You're consuming to escape.
I come to Orlando today to
put the mirror in your face
and ask you to become accountable.
Every single thing that has
not gone my way in my
life is 100% my fault.
I love running VaynerMedia
because every time
there's a problem I'm like,
okay first, this is my fault,
second, maybe I should fire
the person that fucked it up.
(audience laughs)
But what I know is I hired that person.
Or I hired the person
that hired that person.
Which makes it my fault.
I watch people that manage people.
I watch people in here that employ people,
love to spew blame on
everybody but themselves.
I promise you, you wanna get real happy?
If that's what we're aiming,
leave this conference
and realize anything
you're complaining about
or are sad about is,
because it's true, 100% your fault, 100.
(audience cheers)
I don't care that your uncle
stole 400 bucks from you.
You shouldn't have given
your fucking uncle 400 bucks.
I don't care that the government did this,
or systemic that, or your
mom was an alcoholic.
Listen, here's my thing,
if one person on earth
with a similar circumstance to
you won, there's an example.
And there's one of them for everything.
Listen, that doesn't mean
that I don't have compassion.
That doesn't mean that it's not true.
The problem is, you need to pay attention
to who listens to you crying.
Let me give you a preview to who listens
to you crying and complaining about shit.
The other losers in your life.
(audience claps)
It's true, it's one big circle
of everybody complaining to everybody
that the system and
everybody else is wrong.
And it's three people sitting on a couch,
not willing to do shit.
My friends, accountability
and lack of entitlement lead to happiness.
For you to figure out what that is for you
is the biggest thing I'm here for.
And again, when I do the
40 year old and over,
to me the 40 years olds in here and above,
they're the ones that
are in the best position
because the do know logically,
'cause they have context,
that this internet thing is remarkable,
like uncomfortably remarkable.
Like when we all grew up there was
no other part of the world
that you could do at night.
Because this is about practicality.
You could be listening
to me and being like,
yeah okay I'm ready, but damn it,
I have $87,000 in debt, right?
Cool, so my big thing is like
work your job that pays you.
This is where nobody
talks about this shit.
Everyone's like, Gary,
okay I'm $50,000 in debt,
I got you on the side hustle thing,
I'm even committed to starting
my podcast or my content
about my T-shirt business
from seven pm to 11 at night.
I'm willing to put in that work,
but I can't get caught up.
And I'm like, well tell
me about your expenses.
My friends, you wanna talk about something
that has completely become
something nobody talks about?
Nobody talks about saving money.
It's just not a conversation.
There's a very easy way to do this.
If you make 49,000 a year,
live as if you're making 27.
Everybody lives over what they make.
No wonder you can't save money.
Your apartment's too nice.
Of course you can't save
money, your car is too fancy.
Of course you can't save,
you're buying clothes you can't afford.
There are motherfuckers
that complain to me...
Listen, if you're DMing me or emailing me
know that I don't fucking fool around.
When you DM me and say (imitates
crying) I can't, I can't,
the first thing I do
is go to your account.
Don't let me hear that
you're broke as fuck
and the first fucking story I click on
you're drinking a $7 fucking coffee.
If you're broke you're
not allowed to take Uber.
Take the bus, dick.
(audience laughs)
We need to start saving money to get out--
Are you in a shit spot?
Are you in debt?
You don't like it?
There's gonna be no fast track
to a million dollars
that's gonna fix that.
It's gonna be taking a
step back and drinking
a whole lot of humility,
not a fucking french latte.
(audience laughs)
I don't get it.
People are always like, Gary your story
about you building your dad's business
that's not true, that can't be true.
You had money to invest in Twitter
and all that shit, I know your story.
I'm like, okay, right, because when I made
$53,000 a year, I had a
$2,000 a month apartment,
then I moved down to $1,400 one
'cause I wanted to save more money,
and I bought nothing for a decade.
I went out zero times,
I bought no clothes,
I wore liquor T-shirts to fucking work.
(audience laughs)
I fucking spent no money.
Not super complicated.
How many people here are immigrants
or the children of immigrants?
Raise your hands, raise them high
How many people are the children of?
Keep your hands up.
And how many are the actual immigrants?
Awesome, immigrants have
this shit figured out.
Immigrants come here, they work
and they fucking save money.
I went on one and a half
fucking vacations my entire childhood.
Actually, we went to Orlando.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
We stayed in the fucking Holiday Inn
and my mom ate like one
sandwich in the week.
Immigrant shit.
(audience laughs)
Everybody cries about immigrants.
They don't spend money on dumb
shit, motherfucker, try it.
Try it, save money and then do your thing.
It's about patience.
Where everybody gets caught up...
Somebody's sitting here,
Sally's sitting here,
she's 39, she's like okay
this makes fucking sense.
And then she's like, but
fuck, and she's like,
it's gonna take too long.
And I'm like, Sally, you're 39.
Do you wanna be miserable as
shit for the next 60 years?
Or do you wanna have some grinding years
for the next seven and
be 46 and young as shit
and start the process
of actually being happy?
People's complete inability
to take one step backwards
to take two steps forward
is destroying people.
How many people here own their home?
Do you know how many of
those people should sell it?
I'm being serious.
DO you know how many people have
no liquid cash, their home is their drain?
And what they should do is sell the home
and either buy a smaller one or rent
to give themselves liquid to
be able to go on the offense.
But their home, which oh by the
way, has four to many rooms.
Do you know how few people have a home
that actually fits their actual reality?
People have homes with four extra rooms
or live in a town that makes
it look better for them.
Man, there's so many fucking
fucked up moves out here my friends.
I haven't even started.
And I'm just like, Jesus so many things.
And by the way, it all goes
back to what I started with.
Everything good that
happened to me is because of
my inability to hear you
cheering or to hear you booing.
You just don't know me,
and I don't know you.
And I don't fully know my mom,
and she doesn't fully know me.
I'm being serious.
We all know this, only you know you.
So why are you letting somebody else's
judgment dictate your behavior?
(audience cheers)
It's true.
All right, I think I've
made my point on the clouds.
Let's get into the dirt.
There's two places, and
you know where I'm going,
right now that have so
much free, organic reach
that if you post on it
good shit will happen.
- [Male Audience Member] TikTok!
- TikTok, LinkedIn, right?
I've been saying it, you
all were waiting for it.
You made the jokes right now.
You can name it, you can
verbatim say I was gonna say it.
You just tapped your friend and said,
I told you he was gonna say it.
And you still don't fucking do it.
This is some unbelievable shit.
You literally know, you're
talking to somebody now
who for 15 fucking years has
been right, consistently,
of where the under-priced attention is.
I told you for a fucking half decade.
The reason I'm always right
is I never guess, I
just wait to it happens,
and then I just say it the
fastest and the loudest.
It's 100% true, I'm not
a fucking fortune teller.
I'm not Nostradamus, I
don't know the future.
I know the present, and I have no fear.
Gary, you can't do TikTok,
it's for teenage girls.
I'm like, this isn't
communism, I'm doing it.
(audience laughs)
They told me I couldn't do Facebook
'cause it was for college kids.
It's for fucking grandparents now.
(audience laughs)
I'm gonna say it 47 times.
Whether you sell a home,
or for 50 year olds, TikTok, LinkedIn.
Here's why, I'm gonna make it very basic.
Here's how the internet works,
new platforms come along,
lots of users rush to it,
because it's caught fire,
for whatever reason.
The amount of content
being put into the stream
isn't enough compared to how
many people are consuming,
thus the machine shows
more stuff to more people.
It's called organic reach.
How many people here benefited
from Facebook 2010, 11?
Raise your hands, raise them
high, I just wanna know.
You people should know the most.
You know exactly what
happened on Facebook.
It was rocking in 2009, 10, 11, 12.
You built a fan page with
a 150,000 people on it,
you pressed a button,
a ton of people saw it,
they shared it, you built brand.
And then all of a sudden
you woke up one day
and you're like fuck sucks, he fucked me.
Why am I hitting it and it's--
'Cause the organic reach went down
because enough people were
content producing to match the attention.
Everyone's like, they want
the money they want the--
Everyone of these apps only
wants you to stay on the app.
That's their entire business.
They're not changing to more
ads, or they're not doing--
They're doing one thing, keep you on.
Keep you on is their business.
You don't like it and you
leave, they're out of business.
If everybody unsubscribes
and deletes the app
of Twitter tomorrow,
Twitter's out of business.
Only the attention of people, which means
they're aligned with you
not the other way around.
I love when people are like,
oh they're feeding me shit.
People are like, that's so spooky.
I just looked at this picture
and not it's in my Feed.
You looked at that picture
for the same reason
it's in your feed, it's your behavior.
It's your behavior.
So I don't know what to tell you.
I think every single person here
should post three posts a day on TikTok
and three posts a day on LinkedIn.
And you can decide, if TikTok's too young
for your business, that's fine.
But I remind you this, what
you learn on posting on TikTok
may help you in your
business in three years.
Because all of a sudden now, miraculously,
Instagram has started a TikTok competitor
as a feature in Brazil, and if it works,
all of a sudden it's gonna
be a part of Instagram.
And that's where you're
super focuses right now.
And just like you didn't
give a shit about Snapchat,
and you walk around proud
that you never jumped on that,
what you don't realize is the
people that did jump on it
were better at doing Instagram Stories
which made their Instagram better.
You can learn the skills somewhere else
and bring it to a different home.
Everyone's just so
emotional about the home.
I'm on TikTok, not
because I think it's cool.
I'm on TikTok, not because I need
a new platform to talk about.
I'm on TikTok because 1.5 billion people
downloaded the app and
are paying attention.
And that's why I'm on it.
And you're not on it 'cause, oh that's
that dumb shit my niece plays with.
I'm on it with data, you're
not on it because of opinion.
(audience claps)
I think everybody should
consider a podcast.
If you are capable of talking,
I think you should consider a podcast.
Audio consumption will continue to grow.
It will continue to
grow and grow and grow.
Watch this, I want
everybody to look around.
How many people five years ago,
and be honest here, don't
just raise your hand,
this is important, how
many people five years ago
were consistently listening to a podcast?
Raise your hand, raise it high.
Everybody look around,
look around, look around.
We're looking?
Good, good, good, hands down.
How many people are now
consistently listening to a podcast?
Raise your hand?
That, keep it up if you
don't mind, look around.
That's the business I'm in.
I'm in the business of
where is the attention?
The reason podcasting--
Well actually, watch this,
how may people now watch
YouTube videos, including mine,
but aren't actually watching the video,
you're just listening to the audio?
Raise your hands.
Look at this, look.
This is why I get so mad at people.
They're like what about the
lighting, and the production?
One more time, how many people
are just listening to it?
Raise your hand.
These are the same hands that are up
that are telling me they can't do YouTube
'cause they can't make it look great.
The customer's not even looking.
My friends, unemotional
decision making is what
has allowed me the great luxury
of standing at this table.
It's not a table, fuck.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, you guys were being
super kind, I love you Orlando.
(audience cheers)
Listen to me, unemotional,
everything I want it to
be means nothing to me.
How I want the world to be has
nothing to do with what the world's doing.
So many people here are not doing things
on these apps because
they don't like that kids
are at dinner tables on their phones.
They don't like that these
kids can't look at you
in the face when you shake their hands.
The fuck does that have
to do with anything?
(audience laughs)
People are making decisions
about their business
predicated on emotional decisions
of how they, singularly, want the world.
You have that level of audacity?
You have the level of audacity
to think that your opinion
on how the world should be
is how the world should be?
Are you fucking kidding me?
I am fascinated by this.
Gary, I don't like this social
media stuff, it's ruining us.
I'm like, really, explain.
Well the Russians.
(audience laughs)
That's my favorite.
I'm like, let me ask
you a question, Barry.
Do you think when you
went into the poll booth,
miraculously, the
Russians grabbed your hand
and made you pull the fucking lever?
We are fucking good at blaming other shit.
Parents love to blame
social media and iPads
on all the shit that's
wrong with their kids,
yet any time a kid is
looking for attention
and they're busy they're throwing the iPad
at them like it's a
fucking steak to a tiger.
(audience laughs)
(audience claps)
I talk to all these parents.
Oh, Gary the internet's all fucked up.
Hey mom, hey take this, download the app.
(audience laughs)
We live in the greatest
era of non-accountability,
especially in this country,
because this country has
had the great fortune
of multiple decades of
prosperity in continuum
that has completely left us not
having context on real life.
This is a room full of people who get mad
if they don't get enough
likes on an Instagram post
while their great grandparents went
through the Great Depression,
world wars, Vietnam--
Real shit, and we're crying
about the dumbest shit ever.
The world has never been better.
The mainstream media
tells us it's the worst.
I understand how this works.
I come from the Soviet Union.
I know how this all works.
I ask you to understand
that you, for your business,
have the ability to communicate.
Do you understand that what
I'm telling you with TikTok
and Instagram and LinkedIn and YouTube
and Podcasting and Twitter,
used to cost 30 years ago
millions of dollars of
infrastructure to be in the game?
That you would have to buy
a printing press, and deliver newspapers.
That you'd have to shoot
a fucking satellite
into the air and start a TV network.
This would cost tens,
if not hundreds of millions of dollars,
and yet (laughs) we are
not taking advantage of it.
(kid screaming)
That's right!
(audience laughs)
You little three year old,
you fucking get it and they don't.
(audience laughs)
(kid screams)
She fucking gets it.
She's frustrated over there.
She's like these dumb
fuckers don't get it!
(audience laughs)
My friends, do me a favor,
let's make this real simple.
Please use tonight to honestly
figure out why you're not posting.
Because it's an excuse, I hope you know.
Because on Twitter you
can post 40 times a day,
write words, and if you
don't have a designer,
you hit the little GIF button
and they give you a default GIF,
and now you have design for free.
It's not because you don't have
the infrastructure or the money.
And don't even start with me with the
Gary, I don't have time.
That's my favorite.
DM, Gary, I don't have time.
Switch over to the account,
latest Story, Eating 17 Chick-fil-As.
(audience laughs)
Huge shout out to The Politician,
watched all eight episodes last night.
(audience laughs)
Nobody can beat me in 2K.
You have time.
I promise you, if you're not fully happy,
all you have is time.
Because if you're not fully happy,
you need to reallocate your time.
That's the truth.
And by the way, when I say
certain things like this,
I put myself into the
audience and I'm like,
he doesn't get it he doesn't--
I understand that, I understand
being on the receiving end
of that comment, because it's perspective.
Here's a good one, one thing you can learn
about the current political climate
is that life is about perspective.
People see things differently.
We live in a country where there's
two really hardcore points of view,
yet there is only one reality.
It's just the angle you see it in.
I don't judge you here today.
I'm here for one reason,
with the hope that you may be
willing to try a different perspective
if you're not in a great place.
I don't want to come across
audacious when I'm telling you
you have time, and you're
like fuck you dude,
I have three kids, I'm
single parent, I've got two--
I get that.
I'm just saying if you're
an unhappy we have to hack.
I need to audit every minute.
I'm interested, 'cause
otherwise let's not play.
If you're not desperate
to find the solution
if you're unhappy, then don't play.
And this changed--
Man, I just can't get over it.
You know what I really wish?
Tomorrow some weird
like astroid came down,
hit earth and everybody
who's dead is reborn.
I would just love for you to see the way
people that are 150 years old
would look at the world today.
They would be like, you have all this?
They'd be like, I used
to take shits outside.
(audience laughs)
Fuck, you're talking internet?
I'm just pumped you have
running water in your fucking house.
We have lost perspective.
And we have absolutely let judgment
of others dictate our happiness.
I'm trying to figure out
how to suffocate this,
how to get you to go home and
really be set, start over.
There's no process or system or course.
This is a mental fucking warfare.
Why are you not posting on the internet?
It's free.
(audience claps)
I've had the great luxury of hearing
every excuse at this point.
I know them, I understand them.
They're excuses.
It's just like getting into better shape.
The health industry is
the most interesting ever.
There's a seminar going on
right now around health and wellness.
Meanwhile the entire keynote
should be the following,
eat better shit, work out
daily, good night, see you.
This hour that I've dragged
out, here it is in one sentence.
Post stuff on the internet.
(laughs) It is that fucking craziness.
It's that simple, yet it's clearly not
because when my hardest core
fans who cheer and retweet
and fucking put goat
emojis in my comments,
if you're putting goat
emojis in my comments
and you're not posting 10 times a day,
I'm gonna fucking kill you.
(audience laughs)
I don't want your fucking compliments.
I want you to fucking hear me.
I don't want your follow.
Fuck man, I don't want you to buy my wine
or my sneakers either,
on some random shit.
Just go make yourself happy,
what the fuck's a matter with you?
(audience cheers)
I'm giving you the blueprint for free.
How many people saw that deck that
I put out the other day on my birthday?
(audience cheers)
That shit cost me a lot of money to make.
You downloaded it and you were hyped,
and you still haven't
fucking posted anything.
What are we waiting for?
Are you really waiting for
the economy to collapse
and it going back to bad times,
and then you sitting in your room
when you get fucking fired
from your bullshit job
and say I wish I fucking listened?
Like are we really waiting for that?
Is that where we're at?
Are we all just a bunch a bunch of
fucking lung cancer people who smoke
fucking 800 cigarettes a day?
We told you it was fucked up,
and then you're laying at
80, dying from lung cancer.
You're like, fuck maybe
I shouldn't have done it.
The answer is yes, that
is what we are doing.
So now I ask you that the
serendipity of the world
brought us together, here this evening,
can we at least fucking act on it?
Can you please start
making videos on YouTube?
Fuck production value, fuck
you don't have makeup on.
You don't have makeup on?
If somebody says you're ugly--
Fuck man, can I tell you something?
(audience cheers)
Do you understand that if you make a video
and somebody leaves a comment,
shut up, you look so fucking
ugly, put some makeup on,
do you understand that
you should not feel bad?
That you should look at that
comment, take a step back
and say, my god, I feel
so sad for this person.
This person took time out of their life
to watch my fucking video and
spit venom into the comment--
Their life is so fucked.
We shouldn't be mad at haters and trolls.
We should deploy compassion.
If you're the kind of human being
that watches other people's
shit to drag them--
My friends, cliche, misery loves company.
I swear on my children's health,
every negative comment I get,
the entire chemical frame of my body
goes into compassion,
sympathy and empathy.
I mean that.
(audience claps)
Just post content.
If you're weird, you
know if it's scary to you
to go on video, than write, right?
If you wanna start a podcast,
and what you're gonna go--
I do this, then I get a million emails.
Gary, okay, you convinced me,
Orlando was lit, I'm
fired up, I'm doing it.
(audience laughs)
Now real quick, what do I need
to do to set up for a podcast?
I found this thing, I just
bought this fucking course
for $997 to buy fucking,
how to set up podcast.
Like, do I need good lighting?
Do I need a microphone?
No, motherfucker, your
phone has something called
Memos, fucking press the
button and fucking talk, dick.
(audience laughs)
This, this fucking computer
is more powerful than
the computer that Ronald Reagan
had to run the free world.
Every excuse you've got
of not having equipment,
it's in your fucking pocket.
This, this, you have it.
Everybody has it, it's
crazy that we have it.
Enough, please, please make today the day
that you're gonna finally
make written, audio, video.
They'll ebb and flow, they
get hot at different times.
2003, blogs exploded, if you remember.
That was for writers.
Then YouTube comes along in '05,
here comes the video movement.
We've all been in the video movement.
Over the last three years,
we're in the audio movement.
We're in the audio movement.
And by the way, everybody in this room,
everybody here is gonna make a ton of
buying decisions with just their voice,
this Alexa and Google thing, it's real.
You might be listening
to just music right now,
or some joke, because it
hasn't been advanced yet.
But that just like the iPhone,
let me remind everybody
that the biggest app on the
iPhone in the first year
was the app that looked like
it was a beer and you drank it.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, the lighter.
If you think a lot has
happened in technology
the last 15 years, wait
till you see the next 15.
If you are not making content,
you are becoming irrelevant.
I don't care if you're the
alpha in your neighborhood
and you've doing it for 23 years,
and everybody knows who you are.
They're gonna forget real
quick over the next decade.
How many people here are retiring
within the next 10 years?
And I don't mean, before
you raise your hands,
that you're gonna fucking crush it
with some system and buy a fucking island.
I mean you're fucking old and finished.
(audience laughs)
You look too good, I don't see it.
So okay, for the seven of you, cool.
But for everybody else in this room,
if you're not heeding
my call this evening,
you can't imagine the level
of irrelevance you will have
in a decade if you don't
get on this treadmill now.
This marathon is real.
There's a lot of people in this room
that aren't even practicing,
completely disrespecting
the most obvious thing on
earth, free platforms, free.
This is why I get crazy when
organic reach goes down.
They're like, ah they're fucking us.
Really?
It was free.
(audience laughs)
People are mad at Instagram
for a free platform
that can build at scale,
but rushing to pay $4,000
for some dumb shit that's
free on the internet.
It is time to change our
collective perspectives.
The second you can get
your mind into a place
where you're not doing this
for anybody but yourself...
This is why I always bring up Rocky IV.
Who saw that shit, Drago?
(audience claps)
If you remember that scene where he loses
and then he gets super pissed,
and he basically says, fuck you Russia,
I was in the ring for myself,
I wasn't fighting for this
country, I was in it for myself.
That's where I'm trying to get all of you.
You're living this life for yourself.
The way for you to be selfless
and love everybody else,
is to start with being
selfish for yourself.
Make yourself happy.
You're not making anybody
happy if you're not happy.
(audience cheers)
And you're doing stuff to
make somebody else happy,
you're not, you're actually
creating resentment
on both sides of the equation.
So my friends, please take advantage
of the fact that we all got lucky.
Everyone of us could have
been born at a different era.
This could be a key note
about watch out for the black plague.
(audience laughs)
Seriously, you know it's
like a funny thing to say.
People got wiped the fuck out.
I mean it.
We've lost complete context,
of time, and historics.
Most people in this room are
gonna live for 50 more years.
If you're under 30, it
scares me to think about
how long you're gonna live.
Of course, there's the
occasional horrible accident.
Of course, there's disease.
But please pay attention
to what's happening.
The advancements in modern medicine.
This is why I get so going right?
Like this why I always make so much
content about 28 years olds, 25.
Like 30 scares the shit out
of people, on a random number.
On something that made
sense maybe 56 years ago
when people lived to 60 and 55.
Please, please, just
please, figure this out.
If you are producing 25
to 50 pieces of content
of what you believe, what
the value you bring...
Remember to make content
for the audience, not just for yourself.
If you make 50 pieces of content that says
buys this, buy that,
nothing good's gonna happen.
If you figure that out,
so much good can happen.
We're just caught, caught
in judgment and insecurity,
trying to impress people
we don't even like.
Makes no sense, and it needs to stop.
We need to make happiness the
North Star of our society.
I'm done with people saying shit like,
I'd rather cry in my Ferrari.
That's the stupidest fucking
statement of all time.
(audience laughs)
It's so fucking stupid.
People say shit like that
when they don't realize what crying is.
Depression is horrible,
unhappiness is horrible.
Nobody wants to fucking
cry in their Ferrari.
I'd rather be happy as
fuck, taking the bus.
(audience cheers)
A funny thing happens when
that becomes your system.
You start looking for
things that make you happy.
Funny thing happens when
you start doing things
that make you happy, you
start working more, harder.
You become invigorated, you like it.
All of a sudden, funny things
happen when you like it
and you put in the work,
results start happening.
You understand?
Think about your workout regimen.
When you try to go on the
treadmill, that wasn't for you,
but you found some fucking,
I don't know, some class,
or some weightlifting, or something else.
You found the thing that worked for you.
You need to find the professional
thing that works for you.
We need to really have this conversation.
Please, if you love college football,
if you love cutting hair,
if you love fashion,
figure out what you love and
try to start a side hustle,
a podcast, a YouTube show,
an Instagram account,
around that thing, that
thing that's your hobby,
the thing that you want
to do laying in your bed
from eight pm to 12 at night.
And then be grateful that
you can lay in your bed
from eight pm to 12 at night,
and actually make something of yourself
or make yourself happier,
or start that thing.
Because that didn't exist 25 years ago.
This is the greatest era of opportunity.
Please don't get older
and regret not taking advantage of it.
Please use this keynote to
finally get you to make.
Thank you, Orlando.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)